hello oh I'm full colleague from
independent and welcome to our Thursday
coffee talk before we start another
reminder that may fulfill man dependent
is members month we have a special
running right now that if you join film
independent you get two extra months
free that's fourteen months price and
twelve and applies to all memberships
both new and renewing and all mentorship
levels as well so find out more at film
independent dot org today we've got two
good friends of the organization with us
to fantastic
indie ladies I'll do my intros well I'll
start with the first one I invited first
I could friend Lulu on the who won best
feature this year's film Independent
Spirit Awards for her movie
The Farewell also won Best Supporting
female and she's also a Bonnie Award
nominee this year her other film is of
course posthumous with this one how are
you doing hi good good thanks for having
me are you doing up where are you I'm in
LA yeah I'm doing okay
you know trying to stay sane and trying
to stay productive and just keep working
but we're lucky everyone's safe and you
know so we feel pretty grateful cool and
when I asked you to do this you said
you'd love to I asked you like who would
you like to chat with like I know just
the person my good friend Mariel Heller
who won best worst feature at the Spirit
Awards a few years ago for the Diary of
a teenage girl she went on to direct
will you ever forgive me and last year's
a beautiful day in the neighborhood
she's also a nominee for the Bonnie
Award this year at this brewery Ward's
welcome Mariel hi thanks Paul thanks for
having me you are on the East Coast
right where are you I'm in Connecticut
we we fled where we live in Brooklyn
we're really lucky to have a place to
come in Connecticut so I've gone from
cosmopolitan lifestyle to basically
living the farm life my husband's
splitting wood in front of me as I'm
speaking to you all our kids you can
hear rats jumping in the background
whatever that is yeah yeah wild turkeys
walking through it's very it feels like
the opposite of normal life it's very
odd again wood from you guys because I'm
looking for wood in the city we're like
when we get wood for a fireplace
yeah I'll mail you some the way these
work the first time viewers I'm going to
step back I'll turn my camera off and
let these two fantastic filmmakers chat
shop for about half an hour and then
we're gonna take questions from the
audience I use the question button at
the bottom of the screen we'll try and
get to as many of those as possible I'll
come back in about half an hour to feel
those questions but Lulu and Muriel take
it away
okay hey Mari I feel like you and I have
been living weirdly parallel lives on
different coasts sort of since we've
both been heading up writers rooms right
leading into this pandemic how are you
doing it yeah I'm doing good I just
finished my pilot so I feel great it's
just you know finished like done done
well like the first draft but you know
you feel good for a second and then you
get the note on yours like I was there
last week I'm one week
I'm one week ahead of you so I feel
terrible right now oh okay not right not
really I'm not think about that I'm
gonna enjoy this moment um yeah yeah but
you know at least like are you still
right are you still running a room or
are you completely no so we did like a
little mini room I'm leading this
writers room with the project that I'm
doing with this American Life and my
company through big beech and so it's we
did like a four-week writers room and
then went off to each write our script
so
I'm in the phase now of like I finished
my pilot a week ago
everybody's sending me their drafts and
I'm giving notes what what about you um
same yeah so you are a week ahead like
we were gonna finish our drafts and then
go back into the room to all discuss and
rebrand talk about notes together
so you just eliminated that second part
of the room and so we're just trapped
doing drafts and then and then second
drafts it's so funny that you say this
American life and big beach because
those are my partners for the farewell
where yeah connected very connected in
many many ways yes yeah well how how are
you finding writing during the pandemic
um
I mean truthfully I feel really not
productive and it feels like it's just a
bit of a slog to try and get through the
day I mean I'm I'm a mom you know as you
know so like and we're trying to
home-school and so you're men I are
basically splitting up the day and we
each get about three hours to write
every day I'm you know which really
means like two hours and there's always
Wiley's always running in and
interrupting and so it just feels really
hard to concentrate and to like
emotionally be present in the writing
but it's good to have something to focus
on it feels really good to like have
something separate from this life so
just a deep into I don't know I kind of
I feel weirdly jealous of my friends who
don't have kids because I feel like
maybe I could be being so productive
during this pandemic if I wasn't also
trying to become a teacher of a
kindergartner well I mean Barry and I
talk all the time about how people with
kids do it because we have a hard enough
time focusing just with the news you
know the state of the world and
everything and it feels like the day
just flies by every day and yeah just
mentally it's hard because you're like
not sure what's gonna happen are we even
gonna be able to shoot the things that
we're writing I know so I mean I tell a
lot of my
friends not to feel guilty if they can't
write they're not productive because I
think that's like a pretty common thing
where where everyone feels like they you
know have to be the most productive
they've ever been and used this time
somehow I know it's like I used to talk
about how my favorite time in New York
was when there would be a blizzard or
like a subway strike or something that
would make it that I had to stay home
because I was always so productive but
this feels so different because I think
the emotional anxiety and the fact that
we're all just feeling nervous for the
future of the world and the future of
our families and all of those things
that just makes it harder to kind of
imagine being in production again you
know yeah well let's talk about maybe
something happier maybe I agree well how
we met oh yeah let's go into that
because that wasn't the first thing I
thought because Paul said oh it should
be really you know casual and who can
you talk through it and I was like ah
duh that's right I know but do you
remember the actual first time we met
because we have our very clear bonding
trip essentially but we sort of
connected because we were both making
movies with big beach yeah make farewell
I was making a beautiful day in the
neighborhood
pretty closing time yeah did we run into
each other in the hall like I remember
you guys had a meeting one time and I
forget what we had just come back from
China or something but you guys were
like in a room having a meeting maybe my
first real memory of us like actually
chatting was maybe a UT a party or
something like that and getting to be
like yeah you know what I think that we
also met at the spirit awards that you
did that right yes Arian you or would
you guys read and we kind of passed and
we're all going to the bathrooms and we
all chatted and Barry had won and
had--when had made a very sweet speech
and yeah that was a really fun moment
yeah so the spirit Awards were one of
the first times we hung out yeah of the
Spirit Awards they're so fun so fun but
then our friendship real
you know hit hit it stride when I posted
something on Instagram that I was going
to Berlin for the first time because I
was working on a project in the fall and
I was in Berlin without my family for
the first ten days or something like
that and you immediately wrote me and
we're like I'm showing up in Berlin
tomorrow no I'm pretty sure it was I'm
landing in an hour because yeah you were
on the bus on the plane when I saw your
Instagram and I was like wait what and
then and here's the thing right like I
feel like a director well particularly
women directors we've been trying to
find ways of like forming community
beings yeah but um I don't have a lot of
director friends though I have like my
group of director friends that are from
the Sundance labs and I hold on to those
friendships like they mean so much to me
because them it's such a lonesome job as
a director it's so rare that we get to
talk to other people who do what we do
it's so fun when you get to talk to
other directors yeah so immediately I
was like wait when do you land when can
we hang out yeah I was like well I land
in an hour and then you know I got to
get my bags and then I gotta get to
check into my apartment I was like I'll
just be waiting for you yeah and you
were like I'm not doing anything I'll
just have a drink and wait for you yeah
and it was it was such a weird night
because I had some issues with my Airbnb
Brad took you a while it's really
because they gave me the wrong key or
they left the rock I forget now but also
raining so I'm sitting in the law in the
like you know downstairs outdoor area
like courtyard area waiting for the guy
to like go across the city to bring me a
new set of keys like all right all right
and my phone was about to die I was like
is this gonna happen at all I know and
we really didn't know each other that
well at that point do I know and I'm
gonna play key person I just bad I knew
that we ended up having like the best
time for so many days we
to hang out a bunch of times and have a
lot of drinks I I taught you about a
boulevardier you did oh my gosh I forgot
about a bullet I haven't been drinking
them because Barry drinks Manhattan's a
lot so we end up making black
Manhattan's mostly but yeah I've got to
change that I mean I love a Manhattan
but yeah I've taught you about a
boulevardier and I was like oh yeah
we'll be fast friends yes well I showed
up that night and I was like I need a
drink and you were like I've had three
ketchup it was so rare for me to be in
another country without my family -
uh-huh and then we had that um dinner
with your family or at least with your
ma yeah little vegetarian place which
was on my birthday on my 40th birthday
right I got to celebrate your birthday
with you yeah which was so fun um oh no
my kids trying to come in the door
well you can't come in right now you see
this magic of you know of these kinds of
things like whether it's a zoo meeting
or a live interview this would never
happen if we were on a stage it's true
in the theatre although the number of
times that that's happened while I'm
being interviewed or something I can't
even count but yes that's true yes yeah
so what how are you feeling about kind
of getting back into production and what
do you miss most right now about being
in this world not actually being in
production right now well I miss Barry
and I were just talking about it because
my TV series that I'm writing it takes
place in Hong Kong so I thought everyone
is excited about it because you know
that part of the world might be ready
before well we'll probably we'll be
ready before we are for production so we
were just talking about what the process
would be like yeah will we be tested
would we be quarantined before we start
production
because I don't know about Hong Kong but
I know South Korea's reported zero cases
for you know several days now right so
does that mean the entire country is
safe like if we test and network so
Barry said we'll probably be tested land
be quarantined for two weeks or whenever
test it again and then there's probably
gonna be all kinds of restrictions where
you can only go from here to here to
here in order to climb through safe so
that's terrifying because I mean so much
of I've never shot a film in the US and
I've always been you know every project
I've ever made has been abroad and so
much of my process in the prep period is
incorporating things that I discover in
the city into the script to make it feel
organic and so it's like if you can only
go to these designated places if you
can't just stumble around the city
interesting yeah how do you really feel
the life of that place yeah so I know
it's hard to imagine production because
production is so it's such a big
operation with so many people and it
feels like everybody's so close and kind
of you're spending so much time together
it's hard to picture how how this is all
gonna work and I missed that like I
missed the feeling of being you know I
mean I talked about filmmaking so much
as such a lonesome undertaking with the
exception of production which feels like
suddenly you have all you you prep for
so long and it feels so lonely
especially before you're an official
prep it feels like you're writing and
you're alone with your thoughts and then
all of a sudden you have like 200 best
friends who are all there to make the
movie with you ya know so collaborative
and it feels so great at least it's one
it's my favorite part of the whole
filmmaking process yeah me too I didn't
love it I know and and and then you go
into post and post feels once again
lonely I mean it's fun but it feels like
writing a lot it's like just living with
you and your editor so much of the time
and so it's like I'm in post on one
small project right now I'm writing on
another project those were the very
isolated times anyway but it's hard to
picture what that middle period will be
like yeah I mean especially with a TV
series cuz it's interesting cuz very I
feel like Barry and I are also like kind
of sync the way you and I are like I'm
one step behind him he just hmm he
worked with a 24 I worked with a 24 and
then he just wrapped his show with
Amazon Underground Railroad and he's now
in our books and now I'm writing and
gonna go into production with a show
with Amazon and you know he shot like
118 days or something like that he was
basically in production for told you
that which hurts my head to think about
118 days it's crazy but you're I mean
the tough thing is that you don't get
much more time than an indie film right
like that's the you mean hi
well for prep and also for shooting
because yeah they just read pages per
day like you know it's a massive project
it's a much higher budget but I you know
we're starting to talk about that
because I had 24 days in China to shoot
the farewell which is a 90-minute movie
for the diary and 24 yeah and then for
TV is what like the the average is like
12 to 14 days 14 15 if you're lucky per
episode right for 60-minute episode
right if you love me yes you're lucky
right I mean so but that's an hour I
mean you do them it's like you know
pages is is like an independent film but
anyways 118 days for a whole year with
to hiatus is built in or whatever you're
spending your whole year with this crew
they're your family
yeah and suddenly and they got cut off
three days before they finish but then
they came back and they got cut off
three days before oh so they were oh my
god I can't imagine going 118 and being
so close to being done and it being
called that's
and then not having a rat party not
having the know of like it's just it's
so you know lucky I mean being you know
having something in the can right now is
just such gold yeah and and especially
when it's like 11 episode I mean yeah
the number of people I know who have
been in production that got called off
where they were in prep you know people
who were prepping movies and they were
like four weeks into prep four weeks out
from filming and just everything paused
not such a hard place to be where is
it's such a great place to be if you're
editing right now cuz we can get it from
home we can do color correction from
home we can sound mix from home we can
do all of these post things yeah I mean
that's why I'm grateful for the writing
too because yeah you know it is lonely
like it is it's what gets me through the
day when I can finish an episode when I
can think about you know the excitement
of going into production
one day whenever that is and you know
and and and I just keep thinking like if
it takes longer than expected
then all right the feature I'll write
another feature alright you know cuz I
think for me I don't know how you feel
about this but the hardest thing is
finding the time to write because you're
like going going going you you're imp
reduction you edit you're on the award
circuit and then everyone's like what
are you making next and you're like oh I
gotta write for three years or however
long it takes yeah now to even find the
next thing it's yeah I know I agree I
mean having a luxury of time is a really
great thing in some ways right now I
mean how are you feeling about the
difference between TV and film like what
have you done TV before never I've never
been in a writers room I've never been
either yeah wait but you've directed
episodes I've directed TV I get TV but
I've never been in a writers room it was
just funny to like run a writers room
when I was like I've never even been in
a writers room I mean Norma has my
sister has like so many of my dear
friends I know what their lives are like
in writers room so I don't feel like
it's so foreign but
you know it's I think it's the same
thing I felt when I started directing
because I didn't go to film school yeah
I was like am I doing this right
is this the way you're supposed to do
this you know and everybody's analyst
there's no right way to do it do you
feel like it help like how was your
experience running a writers room if you
haven't been in one before like did it
like and the feedback from your writers
the feedback from my writers is like oh
this has been the best writers room I've
ever been in this is so feel so
collaborative and responsive you know I
mean I have a really I have a very
strong philosophy that you don't need to
suffer in order to make good art so
really early on you know like I and it's
also part of my whole thing where I want
to do French hours and I I believe in
having a life outside of filmmaking so I
leave prep at 5:00 I leave the Edit at
5:00 or 5:30 so I can go put my kid to
sleep so similarly I was like yeah we're
gonna work from 9:00 to 4:00 or 9:00 to
3:00 and have like a regular life while
we do this writers room like I don't
want to make anybody feel like we're
just sitting around checking YouTube on
our phones while we should be just
focusing you know so I think everybody
kind of appreciated that I wasn't gonna
waste their time and yeah we're just
gonna kind of do our work and go home I
don't know that I didn't because so much
of what I've heard from so many of my
friends in terms of complaints about
writers rooms is like yeah people
trickle in you spend the first three
hours messing around checking the news
and like then everyone expects you to
stay till 11 p.m. and you know I know
and my writers were telling me that you
and they were saying you know this room
feels so like free and and it's like
surprising how much work we get done for
how many like the limited number of
hours because we did like nine or
sometimes 10 to 5 we would just stay a
little bit longer we would tato after
lunch or whatever and I didn't know that
you're supposed to like have official
like today so-and-so gets to pitch a
story or so-and-so get neither no
and when you also have told anybody I
picked I was like what do you mean fit
just talk like you and I did talk you
know and they're like
am i and I think that helps to not have
have one hierarchy so I had no hierarchy
we didn't have a hierarchy we didn't
have like a number two in the room or we
didn't have anyone in everyone was in
the same position that was part of what
I was clear about you know I've worked
with a writing partner before so I was
like I'm just gonna treat this like I'm
working with the writing partner like
which is very different than writing
alone
and it's a very different process than
when you write alone there's so much
more discussion about before you kind of
lock into an idea but yeah we just kind
of treated it like that and it felt
really natural I was nervous about it
before we started that I was gonna do it
wrong or not know what I was doing but
ultimately it felt totally fine yeah
yeah I really enjoyed it I can't I can't
recreate that energy on zoom' like we've
had a hard time having you know five six
people on a zoom conference and and
still try to keep that energy because
everyone's on different time zones yeah
much going on and jokes don't land like
someone will like I agree those private
jokes go and of like a member over lunch
when you said this and then I'll be like
wait I'm sorry I think that she just
made a joke but you just can we can you
repeat that it's like not the same I
really miss the writers and it's so sad
because our office got shut down like we
were in the B word building and you know
we just like had to pull out of it and
so they were like yep we're gonna move
all your stuff into storage come get
whatever you want it was so sad because
we had basically left it expecting to
come back and to e out and yeah we like
coffee mugs esmirna called it a little
bit early because we had people who had
come from LA to New York and we just
felt like let's let everybody get home
like I don't want anybody to feel like
they're being held here and people were
riding the subway to work and it just
felt like I don't know the writing was
on the wall we were making a lot of
jokes when the whole
corona virus pandemic began we were like
okay so we've got seven neurotic women
in a room like we are so up on this
virus we're like the most paranoid
nervous room about what was happening
like we were so ahead of the curve that
we kind of called it early well that's
good at least yes I mean we didn't we
were we were like wait when did your
room end oh well we were supposed to end
it was supposed to end
March 13th or whatever that Friday was
and we called it on like that Monday
before so like the eighth or ninth the
weekend before me and the producers got
on the phone and said we got to let the
people from LA go home and let everybody
work remotely this last week so that was
our final week anyway um so yeah it was
what a weird time but I agree zooming
isn't the same it just doesn't feel the
same yeah it's really hard I mean I I
already hated conference calls and how
many people are trying to talk over each
other on conference calls yes this is
the exact same issue it's just really
hard yeah the lag I think one on one is
okay but you know you get into like so
many people yeah yeah you can't get a
group dynamic going yeah there's so much
of our writers room feels like it's
about this sort of everybody having
their own position within the room
everybody having their own like role
they play yeah and are you excited about
directing and how many how many episodes
are you directing it's gonna be six and
so we'll see I mean it's it's hard to
figure out when it will happen
truthfully I mean everything feels like
it's slightly on pause in terms of
timing you know or hope I think our hope
probably was to go in the fall but it is
set in New York I mean I
I just feel like it's such a hard thing
because so much of so much of how I've
sort of approached filmmaking always is
that you set a goal and just go forward
toward it like I'm filming in the fall
this is what I'm doing and you just
start chipping away at making panic
that's how I got my first movie made was
like I declared at a certain point that
we were filming even though we didn't
have all the money together and we
didn't have everything we needed but it
was like you have to kind of have a goal
and just work toward that goal right but
right now in time that feels impossible
you know it feels like trying to predict
the future to try and plan toward a goal
so yeah I don't know I know what you
mean I'm sort of like my goal right now
it's almost like I'm hoarding my own
writing like I'm like within this time
I'm gonna just try to hoard as many
pieces of writing as possible both smart
so then maybe in the neck like I have a
future and here's to TV series and you
know and here's another idea and then by
the end of it at least once this is all
over then I don't have to go back into
the writing I'll just be you steal that
as like a philosophy to try to keep in
my head during this time because I think
that is a good way to look at it is like
and I agree it's really hard to find
time when you're making movies like and
I love making movies but they take so
much time and I'm not one of those
people who's great at leaving the Edit
room and going and writing like David
Lowry who in front of us makes me feel
so lazy because we'll be texting we'll
both be editing a movie or something and
I'll be like how's it going and he's
like good and then I go home from the
Edit room and I write for four hours and
like what I go home from the Edit room
and have a drink put my kid to bed and
watch The Real Housewives like what are
you talking about I just don't
understand I don't I'm not that prolific
I can't do it and I can't multitask on
multiple projects like that
I mean it's oh it was so hard for me to
be putting out can you ever forgive me
while I was making a beautiful day in
the neighborhood that was like it felt
like I was cheating on one project with
the other one the whole time
and I felt totally like split it didn't
feel good so I don't know I'm not good
at that process of like constantly
having the other thing I'm writing while
I'm also working full-time on something
else which some people just are grade it
yeah when I try to work on multiple
things which I am right now there's
another feature that I'm not writing but
I'm working with the writer and I end up
getting the two projects confused and
they end up matically like not
intentionally just kind of melding
together right because it's what's it's
what's in your heart in the moment what
you're feeling and thinking about that
makes total sense
yeah like confusing them and I'm even
now thinking I've got to find a way to
separate these projects so that they're
different so that they totally feel
different so that they are exploring
some different things because right now
I'm in it so all of the themes can be
the same but once I shoot and I spend
like a year working on one project I'm
not gonna want to explore the same
topics again in another thing and and
yeah yeah it's a really interesting it's
an it's interesting about who's people
whose brains kind of work well like that
you know who can kind of multitask in
that kind of way and live in multiple
worlds cuz I'm with you it's sort of
what wherever I am whatever mood I am in
ends up affecting my work so much yeah I
know I thought a lot about how I
probably wouldn't have made a beautiful
day in the neighborhood if it hadn't
been under the Trump presidency
like there was something about I felt
like I needed that movie my guy felt
like that was what I wanted to put in
the world and it felt very connected to
politics and similarly when I made the
Diary of a teenage girl I thought I
don't know if I would have felt safe to
make this movie currently like right now
but in 2014 or 13 when I filmed it now I
can't remember what year it was but you
know it was there was something to
resist against there was a safety within
our kind of political system that made
me feel like I could explore certain
things I don't know yeah it changes
based on where you are
solutely and and also where you are in
your life you know like if if you're
single if you're about to have a new
baby if you're you know all of the fears
and all of the questions in your mind go
into this probably not I mean what are
gonna be all of the movies that come out
of this I'm like is it gonna be pandemic
movies or is it gonna be like some
idyllic version of the world is it gonna
be people making movies about like
baking bread oh I mean I I hope my hope
is that they're not too literal like cuz
I want I'm excited to see what comes out
of you know people's creative minds
during this period yeah my hope is that
they're not all just pandemic movies
literally about a pandemic about zombies
about whatever but that yeah really
speak in metaphors you know no I do
think there's something so grounding
about what's happening where so many of
us are feeling like the trappings of
everyday life and the distractions of
everyday life are being stripped away
from us and we are kind of being brought
brought to our needs in some way to deal
with things in a more simple way I think
it's also a really challenging time for
people with mental health issues and
yeah it's a time when people are being
they're not having those distractions
it's a tricky thing yeah well yeah but I
am curious what it will do kind of for
the collective conversation that we're
having in terms of film and TV of like
what what will be this era how will this
era of filmmaking be defined yeah I mean
and it's interesting because Barry and I
talk all the time about how when we
first started as filmmakers the
limitations in many ways even like I
didn't go to film school but I took a
film class and how limitations can often
be so great for creativity it's like a
little bit a project where there's no
dialogue because you're shooting on
super ray and you're not gonna have
sound and so you try to use that within
as part of the conceit of the story that
you're telling and so that's the that's
the thing I try to hold on to is that
you know whatever the limitations
are coming out of this even if we can't
shoot the things we're writing now can
we write something that works within the
limitations though yeah they know in
certain ways the scariest thing to me is
the idea of just having enough money to
do whatever you want because you won't
be as creative you really want to be
kind of pushing up against having to
come up with solutions and compromises
that push you further creatively because
idea I agree it helps you yeah I mean
within limits but but it does help you
yeah hi Paul
hi hi have we reached our 30 limit at 30
minute living I told you Mari and I can
talk forever I know I feel like we're
just having a private conversation that
we actually talked shop enough yeah I
believe you alone if you want for
another two hours there we have about 25
minutes to serve questions
good questions Mary I just want to say I
think your daughter will make a great
director yes Riley is a director in the
making in a way that is problematic for
us that's what happens when you have to
direct your parents the closest or after
I've told you what I need to tell you
yes we tried to take a birthday picture
for a friend yesterday and while Eve
decided to stop the whole thing had a
new concept we had to sit on the couch
in a certain way and do a headstand and
like would not let us take the picture
of the way we wanted to take the picture
so we have a lot of questions people can
submit questions using the Q&A button
bottom of the screen there either or ADA
I'm sorry for mispronouncing that is
firstly says thank you for being so
thank you so much for being incredibly
vulnerable and honest there are some
pandemic and they make related questions
or try and group them together
Lisa Lehmann I could friend Lisa hi Lisa
I would love to know what production
safety protocols you're hearing and what
we could look for in terms of guidelines
will draft be released and also a
question about
potentially could be produced during
extended lockdown periods like animation
virtual or any sort of I I don't think
any protocols are official yet I mean I
feel like there's a lot of talk and you
know one of the things that's been going
around was this idea of people making
movies coming and self-quarantine eating
for two weeks before you start and then
you can't see anybody else which goes so
against for me everything I believe
about making movies that we should all
be able to be with our families and see
our kids and like continue our lives
while we make movies and so obviously
that's a protocol that I won't be able
to make a movie under that kind of you
know protocol it just wouldn't work for
me with what I believe but I think a lot
of people would be willing to do that
and it'll be it'll mean a lot of
childless people or people who are
willing to leave their families you know
going to make movies lunar uh yeah like
Mari said nothing I I don't know
anything official it's just mostly you
know Barry and I talking about what
we've heard or what you know the
speculation is and we were talking about
this earlier about just you know what
are the locations that are gonna open up
first what are the projects that are
you're able to shift the location um I
don't think anybody really knows no
people are talking about people are
making jokes sort of about like filming
a sex scene with two people in different
rooms or you know there's a lot of kind
of like chatter about all of the
ridiculous ways which we will try to
make movies with limited crew and all of
that or doing things on sound stages
where things end up kind of being more
like the way we used to make movies in
the old days and and again like you know
because the series I'm working on is
abroad I think that that's maybe one of
the reasons they're you know people are
more hopeful because you're taking crew
and they're gonna you know be away from
family anyways like whoever
and whoever is local which is very
different from shooting locally where
people do go home and you see their
friends and you have like in many ways
like if you know we go to Hong Kong our
team will probably be in one hotel under
a certain amount of lockdown everyone's
tested everyone's quarantined you're in
a country that has no new cases whatever
might be why they're pushing this
particular project or those projects
that are able to shoot in those places
Shalako asks how do you think new
filmmakers will enter the industry under
current circumstances would quit II like
projects be a strategy worth pursuing I
mean I always say whatever you can do to
make things you should do and that you
know nobody's gonna nobody's gonna do it
for you
nobody's gonna believe in you until
you've made something so finding people
that you want to work with who you agree
with creatively I mean my biggest
jealousy about not going to film school
was really that I didn't get to get a
community of people who I wanted to work
with yeah I felt like I got that through
the Sundance labs but it was so
different and later on and it felt so
good to have other people who you could
actually trust from a creative
standpoint so I think obviously there's
so many places now to make content and
you but you really have to kind of
establish who you want to be as a
filmmaker and make something that really
represents you I think it's always a
tricky thing if you're trying to fit
into a box you know what's interesting I
just thought of and I haven't thought of
before is because we're all thinking
about you know the films that are coming
out this year the festivals that are
shut down
so those films are not able to be
released but let's say that things get
back up next year and you have Sundance
and South by and Tribeca and all these
festivals but what are the short films
are gonna be submitted or future films
like what are the films that are gonna
be submitted if not if people are not
making things I mean there's always lag
time right so there are movies that
weren't ready
for Sundance this year but that are
being edited right now that may end up
there next year
and I mean I think it's gonna be but I
agree there's gonna be this weird lag
time there's gonna be some period of
time where we catch up and run out of
things and maybe it's animated
I mean obviously animated projects are
able to move forward in a way that most
other things aren't yeah and I do wonder
if people you know cuz Barry and I are
always will drive-by restaurants that
are closed or stores that are closed and
it's like is this a time in which
someone really creative might reach out
to a restaurant that's closed and say
and have an idea that takes place
entirely in a high-end fine-dining
restaurants that that is closed right
now and say hey we don't have a lot of
money but we'll give you this if you let
us use our space it's only five people
you know me my DP my sound guy two other
crew member and then the two actors or
whatever like a really tight unit but
maybe you're able to leverage like
locations and things that you weren't
able to before that were when they were
open it's true I worry you know I worry
about the below-the-line people and the
crew members who are gonna be seen as
being obsolete or like who we're gonna
be constantly trying to work around
giving people jobs and I feel like
production value will suffer because of
that
I mean I have a lot of crew friends who
I feel like are seeing people discuss
their jobs being taken away you know as
like we don't need you we'll do it
really small will do a guerilla style
without all these all of these extra
people but of course those extra people
have very vital jobs hunt on set we have
quite a few questions about first
features getting first meters off the
ground
Britany ask you both about the process
of getting them off the ground and any
things that you did that helped sort of
set up those features jeremy asked you
lulu specifically about the process for
getting posthumous off the ground
there's another question here on Kamisha
I hope I'm pronouncing that right about
getting the financing of your thirst
futures you want to hit it for mr. me
Lilla well I had a very unusual first
feature experience so it's it's not one
that I would say that it is typical for
most filmmakers I started working with a
friend who I didn't realize was able to
really finance a film of that size we
just started working together out of
passion and we you know she wanted to
make a romantic a screwball romantic
comedy so I really and said let's shoot
it in one room and keep it really
limited a you know micro budget and so
that I specifically wrote that script
because she was willing to give me even
a micro budget to work on something to
make something and so I pitched a couple
different things and then posthumous
ended up being the one that we agreed on
and then the project snow balled it got
bigger and bigger and bigger but I think
that I was very naive and I just always
said I'm gonna make it I don't care how
it snowballs and even if Bernadette
can't finance it we'll find the rest of
the financing so we just kept pushing it
and and then luckily she was able to
finance it and I could not have
anticipated that when we first met or
when we even first started working on
the project but that said you know my
first feature wasn't something that I
had written just for me and self like
raised the money and so you know the
farewell became a much more personal
project and in many ways a harder
project to finance like that was a
project where I got a lot of knows where
with posthumous it was like I found the
financing first I found someone who was
willing to take a shot on me and I wrote
a project to fit that mm-hmm
I I had sort of the opposite which was
that I was not a director yet but I had
a project that I was
passionate about that I have been
writing and working on for years and
years and years and I was trying to
figure out how to make it into a movie
and I was so sure I wanted to make it
into a movie but I wasn't even sure that
I wanted to be a filmmaker but I just it
wasn't like I want to make a movie but
for me it was I want to make this movie
and then maybe I'll never make a movie
again but I I was lucky enough to get
the advice from an Carrie who was a
producer who I knew at the time she
basically said nobody's going to want to
make this movie you should apply to the
Sundance labs because it would give you
some legitimacy if you got in and and
and I applied to their writers lab and
got in and that kind of changed the
trajectory for me it didn't make it
easier to make it because I think making
your first movie is so hard no matter
what and nobody's I mean it's so rare
for somebody to say like I'm gonna take
a chance on you let's make a movie I
mean mostly I think it's blood sweat and
tears that make a first movie and it
usually takes you know I worked on diary
all told about 10 years and um for me it
was like tiny little steps along the way
more than I could possibly you know go
through in an answer right now but like
getting a small grant from the Maryland
Film Festival that let me make a short
film that I got to Kristen Wiig and got
her signed on and used that to go to
financed ears and got them to sign on
for part of the money and then brought
on other people it was just like over
many years chipping away and at some
point saying we're shooting in the fall
and just deciding and pushing forward
and pretending that I knew what I was
doing when I didn't yeah and I don't
think there's like one way to make a
first feature or what one first feature
has to look like nowadays it's cuz I
have many friends who have been trying
to get their personal projects off the
ground haven't been able to but are
offered a studio project because they've
done like TV series or they they've show
run before and so there's a company
that's willing to give them you know a
genre project that's not necessarily
there's in that same kind of way but
they're given an opportunity to make
something and I think the question
becomes do I say no to these things to
make sure that the first thing I do is
really personal is my own story is
something that I've written or and and
that's a really hard question because
because of course if like that studio
project ultimately doesn't end up being
your in your voice or you don't think
it's good and you're taking notes from a
studio because it's really their project
your name is attached to it but at the
same time it's a chance to like pop that
first feature you know
cherry which in a way like you get
judged when you haven't made a first
feature or you haven't made and yeah I
think it's a privileged position to be
able to even talk about whether you
would take that job or not obviously but
I think if you can if you can try to
make your first feature something that
is actually from your voice whether or
not you wrote it hopefully you did but
whether or not you did it's something
that reflects the type of filmmaker you
want to be I think that's how you stand
out I do think that's how you make a
first feature or for you I think what
you're kind of saying is like the
farewell function does that that gives
gives you a certain amount of just
people understand who you want to be as
an artist they're like okay I see you
and I think it's tricky when people kind
of feel like they need to take a project
because it's gonna get made but it may
not actually reflect who they want to be
as an artist yeah it is tricky but you
know I also for me I know that I
wouldn't have made the farewell the way
it was made if I hadn't made posthumous
because I didn't go to film school I'd
never been on a set so in many ways my
approach to posthumous was as a producer
was really learning or as a film school
student really learning like how to run
a set you know even learning what
coverage meant and then on the farewell
I was able to say you know what I don't
need coverage like I feel very confident
that this shot is gonna work in a one-er
and I can just get the master and I'd
rather spend the entire time getting
this blocking and
right on this master cuz that's what I
want to use because it's risk whereas on
my first feature I've I for me anyways I
I took less risks just because I really
didn't know what I was doing and relied
a lot more on my crew and you know
everybody has different like
perspectives like you know a woman of
color mmm their their story might not be
getting the financing this or if it's a
subtitled film that someone else might
and so it just to get them going just to
make something just to do something just
to keep learning you know get on a set
direct something you might want to say
yes that but it's not an easy question I
have a question for you Maria about the
Diary of a teenage girl I mean one of
the things that you don't do when you
make a film if you want to keep a budget
down it's make a period film and this is
San Francisco in the 70s so how do you
capture I think he has a great sense of
time in place
I do capture that when you're
constrained by a relatively low budget I
mean I think that was a real case of
what I didn't know not being able to
hurt me because I didn't after I made
that movie everybody said that I did all
of the things that you're not supposed
to do on a really low budget first
feature and I had no idea because I
didn't go to film school I didn't know
that was something to be afraid of I
didn't know doing a movie with I mean I
think I had 40 locations in that movie -
I didn't kind of follow any of the
things I was supposed to follow I also
had voiceover which everyone was like oh
you never do voiceover in your first
movie it's so it's death and I just
didn't know that these were rules um
I've never heard that rule no voiceover
on your first movie I don't know
somebody told me that after the vac just
in all of the ways that I messed up
apparently but I guess the thing was for
me because because I had worked on that
project for so many years and I think by
the time I filmed it I had written 85
drafts of that script I knew it so
inside and out and knew everything that
I needed it to be that I actually felt
like I was able to be really bold with
my first film making choices I
I didn't know what to be afraid of so if
I wanted to do a scene in an all-in-one
shot I did it because I almost didn't
know the things I should not do you know
there was a freedom in the fact that I
had never done it before and didn't
understand all of the ways that those
things can go wrong I didn't understand
how many ways doing a 1976 movie in San
Francisco could go wrong people also
said San Francisco's the hardest city to
film eluvian for me it was all cheats it
was like a lot of the city hasn't been
remodeled finding locations shooting
into the buildings we had no money for
cars you know we we put ads on
Craigslist saying do you want your car
to be famous do you have a car from the
60s and 70s do you want to come down I
mean we made people 20 bucks out in my
pocket to come bring their cars down and
be in the movie we did everything in the
most budget way you can possibly imagine
and it was really just scrappy and it
was out of love and everybody kind of
coming together it was also my family
and my husband's family were all in the
Bay Area
everybody kind of banded together to try
to help us figure out how to make it but
I kind of believed that the period peace
thing is is a myth like I think you can
do it I've now made three movies which
technically our period movies and I just
don't think it's something to be afraid
of I think if you have a great costume
designer who can really see beyond
things and who knows how to you know
work the thrift stores you can figure
out a way to make I don't know that I
think there are cheap ways to do period
stuff it just requires creativity yes it
still pops I'm Cisco still look like
17th so much of San Francisco still
looks like it does in the 70s and
because I grew up in the Bay Area I had
this really fierce desire to represent
San Francisco correctly because in film
it's a city that has not been
represented very well um everybody who's
from the Bay Area kind of feels like you
know like Woody Allen came and made that
movie in San Francisco and it felt like
a New York movie just put in seven
sisqó none of the characters felt like
they were really from there it's a place
that has a really specific culture and
that culture is something that you can't
really understand I think unless you're
from there but so I really really wanted
to do that city well and show it in the
way that I knew that city to be and
having grown up in the Bay Area like the
culture of the people the way the people
interact with each other the kind of
deeper philosophical culture behind it
of openness and kind of the new a genus
and how that really affects kids and
relationships between grown-ups and
adults and the deeper cultural questions
of a city that you just don't see when
you just take a movie that could be
anywhere and just plant it in that city
sorry you know I just said maybe you
know you if you're doing a period piece
you might not and you don't have a huge
budget you might not be doing like you
know entire shots of the entire city you
might limit it but but we've found ways
you know like we went up and found high
peaks where we were like alright put
this camera super low where you can't
see the cars and we did a few paint outs
that we planned for and could afford you
know and we found ways to give it scope
you know filming in parks keeping away
from cars shooting into certain
buildings we found ways to give it scope
it felt like you know but it's
creativity and a great DP who can help
you to see things in that way i'm tyler
asks the studio is like Marvel are
hiring a lot more indie filmmakers to
direct their films is this something
that interests you or do you want to
work on smaller more personal films I
don't know I mean I I can't say anything
I have no desire I don't think the
budget is the thing that's gonna drive
me one way or another for me it's about
story and project and things that are
gonna touch my heart and that feel like
I want to put into the world I mean I've
made movies on very different budgets
now between my three films they've grown
exponentially and
they don't feel that different like like
we said making a movie I made diary in
24 days I mean can you ever forgive me
in 28 and it had a ton more money and
then I made a beautiful day in 33 and so
it's not like having a huge budget I
mean maybe Marvel money makes you feel
like it's a totally different ballgame
but it all is the same challenges and
it's whether it's touches you and speaks
to you
yeah same I'm I'm I would love to to do
a superhero movie I would love to you
know do action sequences like none of
that stuff is what's keeping me from
doing the Marvel movie it is it comes
down to the script it comes down to the
themes that are explored and and I do
believe out like a you know I've said
this before that if if to jump from a
very very small indie into like that
system it's a different it is filmmaking
much more by committee and you're you
know much more it look at a budget comes
different kinds of pressures and
responsibilities and politics to
navigate and for me it's like I think
the more you establish your voice
artistically the more just having spoken
to friends the more freedom you might be
given by the studio whereas if you jump
too early it's in a way it almost feels
like they're doing you a favor by giving
you that and that's the situation I
don't want to be I agree if I were to do
a movie like that I would need to know I
was truly in charge and being given the
amount of creative freedom that I've had
in all three of my movies that really
matters to me and I would never want to
feel like I was being told how to make
that movie yeah that's my biggest fear I
think about doing one of those movies
yes because I know people it can break
you
you know like experiences like that
where you don't agree but you're forced
to keep your name on the project force
to tell a story or explore a theme in a
way that doesn't feel true to your
values or you don't feel trusted you
don't feel like people actually believe
that you
you are the one with the vision behind a
project I think the thing about
filmmaking is it really does have to
have a clear leader and as much as I
love collaboration and I feel like
filmmaking is such a hugely
collaborative art form and that's part
of what I love and I love bringing out
the best in the people I'm working with
my DP and my editor and everybody
getting to feel like they're bringing
the best they can to the table and I'm
not telling people what to do but there
still has to be whose vision are we
following at the end of the day when
this person doesn't agree and this
person doesn't agree we all have
different visions of where this is going
who's telling us what movie were making
yeah it has to come from one person and
when you make a movie like that I think
it can be really hard to be that person
and you often are not given the trust
you need agree Kelly says to you Mary a
lot of question but hello from the Bay
Area I'm writing a limited series that
takes place in 1978 in old California
and I keep getting forests back I feel
more confident now oh good yeah the bear
is the best it was a great place to
shoot a period piece our crew was
amazing there are not as many crew
members there and so you really have to
find your people but we had an
incredible crew I mean it was such a
magical shoot that we had in the Bay
Area it was really really hard but it
was really incredible and it's a
beautiful city I mean it's a beautiful
place to film people just I don't for
whatever reason people are a little more
afraid of filming there but it's just a
it's such a gorgeous place to capture
for both of you for us says how do you
separate yourself from writing and
rewriting your film when you're
directing your film as well I I rewrite
so so so so so so so much before prepped
that I try to get to a point where I
feel like I have overly questioned every
single bit of the script by the time you
get there but I still end up rewriting
yeah I love the I mean that's the thing
that I've had to really learn is that
you know films are made in the rewrite
process you know very rarely is for me
anyways I mean maybe other people have a
different process but I have to in order
for me to get through my first draft I
have to think of the first draft as the
the clay that I'm sculpting you know but
that it's I'm just collecting my
materials and I'm putting it all there
in the pile into a shapeless form and
then as I rewrite I'm chiseling away and
starting to see what this sculpture
wants to be and and and and so even when
I'm directing something that I don't
write it's in that rewrite process where
I'm doing my pass I didn't work that I
start to find the tone I start to find
the voice because so often you might get
a script that's great but it's like it's
a drama here's the drama and I'm like
how do I subvert that how do I you know
make it funny or how do I make it feel a
little bit weirder you know and and I
think that's the the writing directing
like connection I will say I agree with
all of that and I think rewriting is
writing and anybody who claims the thing
right of perfect first draft is [ __ ]
but but I do think it is sometimes hard
when you're actually in production to
resist sometimes you have the urge to
rewrite just because something's not
quite working in the moment sometimes
that's an indication that there's a
problem on the page but sometimes you
have to figure out why you're not
capturing what's on the page right you
know sometimes you have to be like no
I'm not just gonna rewrite this
maybe we need to reblock it maybe we
need to put the camera in a different
position maybe we need the actors to
have a different rhythm like there was a
reason why we landed here and if you
trust your script sometimes going back
to the script and not just tossing it
out and I've seen directors who really
just if if something doesn't work
immediately they toss the script out and
try to rewrite it rather especially in
TV but I think it's that can be kind of
a slippery slope and sometimes really
going back to this script and going why
did we write it this way what what were
the things we were trying to convey what
are we missing I mean
I go through every scene and just if I
say to myself if everything goes wrong
and I only capture one thing what's the
thing in this scene I have to capture
like I have to get this moment where
this exchange happens he changes how he
feels about her or she finds her
strength or whatever that won't
emotional turn that has to happen and
you can say even if that's the only
thing I get right that's the thing we're
gonna capture and usually your script
has those clues if you've worked long
enough on it and it's in a positive
enough place by the time you start
filming that sometimes it is tempting to
just throw it out on a day and you you
shouldn't you should figure out how to
make it work yeah and I think that's
even a like I've discovered that the the
problems that I've had in the script but
I'm like no it's fine let's just keep
pushing like they are still a problem on
a problem in post-production but if you
know what like like you were just saying
what that scene is about not the
dialogue you know you can fall in love
with dialogue but you have to know okay
this is a scene that's all about these
two people connecting this is where they
fall in love this is the moment that
they fall in love and then when you get
to set you're not just gonna toss it out
or completely but you might say you know
what we don't have the time to shoot all
this dialogue right because you know
whatever the reason is we're losing
light you know where she you know the
day is much shorter
oh hi Wylie like you know I I think
that's where you can are you can like um
you know you can go I don't need it this
dialogue let's just do this whole scene
one shot and get it in the next 15
minutes and we always have that pressure
you always have people going like do we
really need this do it does it can we
yeah
can we skip this or can we just get a
short thing instead and sometimes you
can and sometimes you can say okay we
could just get this in one look or we
could get this I just need to see this
longing or I just need to see this
wistful look or I just need to see you
guys connect or touch each other and
that would do enough but if you
know what that scene is and you you can
do that yeah and that's always the best
because sometimes a lot of times it ends
up being better right because you're
forced to
again the limitations and then sometimes
I'll get a question where people will be
like like this scene is so great and
it's just silent and you know how did
you know - just do it silent you're like
it's because we didn't have time and so
it ought to be a whole conversation that
I get but now it just turned into a hug
you know but people think that that is
the way it was planning all along right
but you have to know your story so
inside and out in order to be able to
make those calls on the day yeah Maria
had a question about living with having
a filmmaker partner and whether they're
involved in the rewriting or like
feedback and we have in common right I
know we definitely talked about this I
mean my husband does such different
types of movies than I do like such big
broad comedies but and I very much are
involved in each other's work probably
him more in mind than I am in his like I
am sort of guilty of not always
understanding or getting the jokes that
he wants to tell in his projects like
like when he told me he wanted to write
this song called dick in a box I was
like really stupid like don't do what I
really don't like that I can't really
get as involved in his stuff but he was
a producer on Diary and was incredibly
supportive in getting that movie made
and so early on like he's been very
involved in many processes from me but
it it's a lot less now that we have a
kid because it feels like he can't be on
set with me if I'm filming a movie cuz
he has to be primary parent and vice
versa so as much as we'd like to be able
to and we watch cuts of each other's
things and read things read scripts and
stuff we can't be quite as involved as
we used to be I also used to kind of
like when they made their first movie
hot rod I was on set most of the time
kind of just giving my thoughts and
feedback and like being a support a
supportive person in a presence and we
can
do that as much now that we're parents
yes Alexis who is online says he cannot
offer or she can offer some referrals
for people in the Bay Area so if there's
any one bay area that was support email
education that film independent org
Lexus if you could say connect you we're
pretty much out of time here apologies
for not getting to all these questions
our final one for both of you is always
what are you watching what what can you
recommend people that is outside out of
the algorithms other than no Real
Housewives
that's all I'm watching now if that's
that's what's getting me through this
pandemic watch the movie we're watching
I mean that's the one thing is we're not
involved in each other's work um and and
haven't been and and right now even
though we're like quarantined together
and both working on things I'd like to
have that separation but the one thing
that we do have together is that we
watch something together every single
night every single night so it's been a
lot of television we're watching right
and with a lot more than normally we try
to watch more films but just we need
some just like silly escape or whatever
but we've watched a lot of great
television like we watched unorthodox I
heard that I'm excited to watch on
Rathod on yeah we watched never never
have I ever
mm-hmm it's amazing we were like we'd
finish the whole thing in two days it's
it's so good but we watched Alaris
recently the ena so we're going back and
visiting some some older films that
either Barry loves or that I've loved I
love that the other person hasn't seen
before that's so fun I wish we had more
time for that we've started the crown
from the beginning because we've never
watched a crown yeah it's so delightful
and I mean there was a whole crazy story
line about when London got shut down
because of the horrible thug that was
really Smaug from all of the coal
everyone's in masks and it felt a little
too much for right now to kind of see
people dying in hospitals with masks on
but other than that it's been good
escapism and just beautiful filmmaking
and beautiful acting and it's nice but
because we have a kid we just don't have
the time I would love to be making our
way through Film Archives and like
really getting to enjoy I've also been
watching projects of my friends who are
editing projects who are sending me
things and then I get to give notes on
things and that's my favorite thing to
do right now yeah it's so wonderful when
you're like this isn't my project I get
to watch it I get to give you thoughts
you get to see it better and better and
it makes you feel connected to something
outside of your own little home whatever
that is right now I just so I'm grateful
that I'm getting to watch cuts of other
people's stuff yeah well if you haven't
seen train to Busan I just have to say
we watched that and it was one of the
most fun nights of viewing that we've
had so far
train to Busan and then there's the
animated prequel Seoul station
oh no but yeah I mean it's very
quarantine it was very like it makes
sense to watch it during the quarantine
it's about zombies and whatever but it's
so well done and it's fun and we were
both just like screaming at the top
that's great have you thinking no I
haven't seen that it's a another Korean
zombie show but it's set in sort of 16th
century Korea oh it's a series yeah okay
great another spin on the Korean Zombie
thank you both
this has been fantastic this has been a
coffee talk with film independent don't
forget that we have a special running
look right now
14 months of memberships for prices well
my two months free no matter which
membership level and whether you're a
new member or a renewing that box but
I'll say like
and also my thank yous to Mario hello
Thank You Marielle thank you this was so
fun obviously Lulu and I could talk
forever it's really fun well just do it
own some time Mari but exactly well if
you want to come back soon and suggest
another pairing we love we'd love to
have you back and also Lulu Wong thank
you Lulu thank you for having me come
back soon
you both stay safe healthy and sane and
we'll see you both soon
[Music]